Santiago en efecto han sido dos semanas
de absoluta incertidumbre política de
tenso clima político y electoral Y es
que efectivamente hace contados minutos
el tribunal supremo electoral oficializó
la segunda vuelta presidencial en
Guatemala es decir que para el próximo
20 de agosto los guatemaltecos podrán
elegir presidente entre los dos
candidatos que habían pasado en la
primera vuelta Sandra Torres por el
partido une y Bernardo Arévalo por el
movimiento semilla el pleno de
magistrados en rueda de prensa dijo que
estudió a profundidad todas esas
revisiones de actas y devotos que
hicieron las juntas electorales
departamentales y desestimaron cualquier
impugnación que habían hecho los
partidos políticos que aducían que había
ocurrido un fraude o irregularidades
electorales de manera que así con cerca
de 900.000 votos Sandra Torres Se
confirma como candidata que pasa segunda
vuelta y Bernardo Arévalo que fue la
sorpresa electoral la persona que estaba
en las encuestas en el octavo lugar y y
ahorita ya Se confirma que con sus
650.000 votos pasa a segunda vuelta y
entre ellos dos habrá un nuevo
presidente
Qué significa que implica esta
cancelación de la personería jurídica
del partido semilla que ocurre justo
cuando como bien nos contaba se
oficializaba que su candidato competiría
en la segunda vuelta
Exacto ocurrió apenas unos minutos antes
de que el tribunal supremo electoral
oficializara los resultados de manera
que la situación es la siguiente el
mismo fiscal que está señalado por los
Estados Unidos de ser un actor que
favorece la corrupción es el que
comunicó que desde su fiscalía la feci
ordenó a través de un juzgado o es un
juzgado el que ordena la cancelación de
la personería jurídica del movimiento
semilla aduciendo dos dos temas dos dos
problemas el primero de ellos es una
presunta adhesión de ciudadanos al
movimiento semilla de manera irregular
es decir que se encontraron en esas
listas de ciudadanos firmas falsas
firmas que no concordaban con el nombre
12 personas fallecidas dentro de esas
listas y que además el segundo problema
es que se dice que el movimiento pagó
desde siete quetzales es decir un dólar
por política y se pagaron cerca de 25
mil o sea se habrían pagado acerca de 25
mil personas para que el partido se
pudiera constituir entonces ahí se abre
una puerta desde la fiscalía a que haya
un caso de lavado de dinero o activos
sin embargo pese a esta notificación de
parte de la fiscalía y de este nuevo
caso que se llama corrupción semilla
quien tiene toda la primordial fuerza en
este tema es el tribunal supremo
electoral dicen ellos que se van a
imponer insisten en que esta presidencia
se gana en las urnas